leaders and business chiefs from across
the asia-pacific region have gathered in
Russia's port city of Vladivostok for
the Eastern Economic Forum on the
sidelines of the event President Putin
in his Chinese counterpart have been
holding closed-door talks our
correspondent Lee Petrenko a small
details of what's going on there the key
messages from Vladimir Putin and Xi
Jingping
in Vladivostok were that there was great
trust between Beijing and Moscow when it
comes to politics defense and security
business ties will keep growing stronger
and stronger and most importantly
Beijing and Moscow are looking to get
off the dollar hook at least when it
comes to bilateral trade amid mounting
pressure from Washington should the two
succeed in ditching the dollar as their
main currency of trait this could be a
clear signal to other countries after
all if Moscow and Beijing could pull it
off why couldn't others the Russian
presidents spent almost the entire day
with his Chinese counterpart there were
all kinds of events and different rounds
of talks they visited an exhibition
together
besides this a boat Factory for one of
the rounds of talks the leaders of
Russia and China were joined by the
wealthiest businessmen from the two
countries and there was also a behind
closed door session the Russian
ambassador before that session began had
hinted that Syria would be brought up
anyway judging by what was said on
Tuesday there is every sign that Russia
and China will continue to act as team
players on an international and global
scene earlier we heard from investor Jim
Rogers and other experts are telling
that former among other topics they
touched upon the ongoing trade wars
trade wars have never worked for anybody
and no one has been
a trade war so this is not a good thing
which is happening for us like this
everybody can find a way is to trade
with each other even if there are trade
wars that's expensive perhaps but this
is a good way for people to share and
say what do we do and anybody who knows
history and economics knows trade wars
don't work countries like China Russia
Japan India and others who do believe
that the world must remain integrated
must work together must create new forms
of cooperation and collaboration have to
put capital both political and money on
the table to preserve and serve this
particular cause and forums like these
where we are today are actually the new
forums of tomorrow it is in the East
Eastern Economic Forum more than the
World Economic Forum perhaps that you
might find solutions for the Asian
century
you